bassem bonjour alors un point presse
vient d'avoir lieu qu'est ce que l'on
peut en retenir
effectivement olivier un point de presse
vient d'avoir lieu on a pu écouter le
rédacteur en chef de wikileaks ainsi que
le père jean la 100g l'avocate de singe
et un point de presse qui a été donnée à
l'heure du déjeuner il ya une pause dans
l'audience de cette deuxième journée
d'audience dans le procès historique de
julian assange est poursuivi par les
américains pour la publication 2010 et
de documents classés top secret avoir
mis en danger la vie de certaines
sources certaines personnes des
allégations qui ont été contredites par
les avocats de julian assange durant
cette première phase ii 2e une journée
de l'audience son avocate est revenu sur
ce qui a été dit par les américains elle
a parlé de mensonges que julian assange
était présenté comme une menace alors
qu'il n'avait fait que son travail en
tant que journaliste à l'appareil d'une
violation de la liberté d'expression et
la liberté de la presse je vous propose
d'écouter jennifer robinson l'avocat de
julian assange
l'accusation a ouvert le dossier en
citant une déclaration du journal the
guardian en 2011 qui prenait ses
distances et condamné julian assange
pour avoir publié les câbles
diplomatiques
cela dit cette accusation ne vaut pas
car c'est le journaliste du guardian qui
a divulgué le mot de passe lui même je
pense donc qu'il est vraiment important
de prendre note enfin de tenir compte de
la chronologie qui a été présenté
aujourd'hui au tribunal
julian assange a effectivement pris des
mesures de sécurité importantes et
responsables pour essayer de protéger
ces documents elle a également affirmé
que pour aucun procès aux états unis en
vue d'une extradition en vertu de
l'espionnage ac serait une violation des
droits d'expression de la liberté julian
assange également est intervenue au
micro de la presse pendant cette pause
le rédacteur en chef de wikileaks qui
est revenu sur les conditions de
détention de julian assange disant que
c'était des conditions très dures et
inhumaine à julian assange qui s'est
présenté affaibli pour cette deuxième
journée d'audience il a dit qu'il était
menotté 6 x étaient déshabillés deux
fois qu'on l'avait privé de ses effets
personnels juste avant l'audience
il est revenu sur une succession de
mensonges il a même déclaré que
certaines publications faites par
wikileaks dans le cas de cette affaire
aurait été
divulguée par des organes américain
avant même que oui qui se puisse les
publier donc voilà une succession de
d'incompréhension durant cette deuxième
journée d'audience qui devrait reprendre
dans quelques temps en attendant comme
vous pouvez boire juste derrière moi
énormément de personnes sont amassés ici
des gilet jaune français également des
pancartes et scandant le slogan cette
violation de liberté d'expression et
surtout la liberté de la presse il
refuse d'extradition de julian assange
et demandent tout simplement la
libération de julian assange reviendra
bien sûr sur cette deuxième journée
d'audience dans les prochaines éditions
après la pause déjeuner ici à londres
merci beaucoup bassem pour toutes ces
précisions ben hassen chébili en direct
de londres